President Biden's migrant mess is
somehow getting worse after a standoff
in New York City dozens of adult male
migrants are camped outside the
three-star hotel that once housed them
and they're refusing to give up their
luxury taxpayer-funded rooms after the
city tried to ship them off to a newly
constructed shelter Joe Biden could have
seen this for himself the big guy was in
the Big Apple today but no he was too
busy patting himself on the back raising
money with his rich friends local
officials are fuming over the situation
they say Lefty activists are stoking
unrest by filling the migrants's head
with nonsense about the new shelter
for all men it's only four bathrooms if
one gets sick everyone gets sick it's
very ugly the beds are horrible
they're a piece of fabric they're like a
military bed mayor Eric Adams has had
enough he went to the new facility to
show it's really not that bad
it doesn't matter if it's Ellis Island
or the Brooklyn pool terminal or is any
of our ports uh it is all rooted in the
American dream you pursue the dream here
and when you meet someone like Wilson
you walk through I just had to come here
when I started hearing all the rumors
about it was too cold
my brother got on shorts she's inside
it's warm inside about the food not
being there of you know healthy food is
presence even the snacks are healthy we
just need to stop the anxiety but hey
it's no wonder migrants don't want to go
anywhere an employee at a different
Hotel say it's a free-for-all
chaos total chaos I mean there's no
accountability the city is so-called
running the program
um allows these people to destroy these
rooms this is not your home
um unfortunately uh the ones that are
paying the prize is the hotel workers
local six union workers those guys and
those ladies endure a lot of disrespect
from the migrants and there is some nice
migrants but there's too much alcohol
too much drugs and too much violence
Greg how do you feel about the
migrants's attitude about not wanting to
live here or there especially since
we're all paying for it I think once you
see migrants turning down free good
stuff given to them under the assumption
that they would be grateful after much
suffering and hardship I'm beginning to
think that their hardship was greatly
exaggerated they're coming here not
because uh they're you know refugees uh
in danger from climate or crime or
poverty it's incentivized by our country
to come here for jobs and free stuff
because what desperate Refugee comes to
a sanctuary and complains about room and
board it's not somebody in a desperate
situation I'm beginning to question that
their entire Journey was not a true
hardship uh if you're fleeing from
something it had nothing to do with root
causes it has some it has something to
do with what you're going to get when
you come here and it's clear like I
there was a question that nobody wanted
to ask including me because you were too
scared to ask why is it where migrants
coming from Guatemala look far less
fatigued than say a typical participant
of a 5k Charity Walk when they were
coming over they were healthy they were
young they were wearing decent clothes
this is not the way I envisioned people
that were on the run for their lives
where were they dropped off I don't know
how long were they walking I don't know
but it seems to me that maybe we're not
being told the whole story here if
somebody comes here after Dire Straits
shouldn't they be like oh thank you so
much not like hmm I don't really like
tuna fish do you have any hot pastrami
and rye and also you know these rooms
are we we are being taken for a ride
here this is a 300 a night rooms right
so we have a right to complain and I'm
pro-immigration I want I want more
immigration with adjustments based on
what our country needs but I'm sorry
we're paying 300 bucks a night that this
and they're complaining
that means this thing was a scam then we
were also told Dana that it was all
families and now it turns out it's all
single men well the other reason that
they need them to leave the single men
to leave to go to Brooklyn is because
it's not because that hotel is now which
by the way this hotel right down the
street from me it's not like they were
gonna open it back up to tourists it's
because there are more migrant families
expected and the migrant families are
going to take over those rooms so that's
what that's how that works the activists
are there on the scene and they're
telling them the law in New York is we
have a duty to shelter that's what it's
called so they know what they can ask
for but the thing is that when you cross
the Darion Gap like if you actually go
through that jungle and you have gone
through that you I don't cannot imagine
complaining about a scrap of fabric as
your bed
um today Biden did the the tunnel over
there by Hudson yards there's a new
Lincoln Tunnel this is something that
Chuck Schumer has wanted for a very long
time Chuck Schumer gillibrand the entire
Congressional Delegation has said
nothing about this Biden they cleaned up
El Paso so much that he didn't even see
anything when he finally went to the
Border if they had stopped by there
today you know as presidents sometimes
do these
um fake off the Record like I'm just
going to stop and get an ice cream you
can do it for things like this too like
I just want to see what's going on and
it would have been very eye-opening
because I drive by it every day and it's
just getting larger everyone slept
outside last night it was snowing this
morning and it's not good for them it's
not good for any of us and I do feel for
Eric Adams because he is at least trying
to come up with some Creative Solutions
perhaps he's not as strong in terms of
getting the Biden Administration to
accept some responsibility but he did
say okay well maybe I can try this maybe
I'll try the park maybe I'll try the
ship better than de Blasio let's put it
absolutely 100 so I I don't see an end
to it
but I feel it's really depressing well
and I guess they settled on Brooklyn and
they have a ping pong table there with
oranges judge yeah well you know one of
the things that that Eric Adams I think
is trying to do is trying to explain
that the the the uh you know that they
have healthy food and they have it's
warm and everything is good and I'm
gonna go there myself let me tell you
what the problem is the problem here is
that this Administration is forcing
people like Dana who live a block away
from that hotel is forcing kids who have
to go to school to walk by these tents
and these shelters and is forcing cities
like New York to pay 650
000 a night to take care of the illegals
with no help from the federal government
what the government has done is they've
sent them in they object if any
Republican Governor now Democrat
Governors are doing it or starting to
move the problem into the interior into
the Northeast you know they object to
that they you've got to recognize that
this is a problem of Biden's making by
two and a half million people coming
into this country and what is it 900 000
getaways in two years of course this is
going to happen of course you've got
people like Eric Adams who's like trying
to say we're doing the best we can and
I've been very critical of him too I do
feel badly for him if he's cutting the
New York City budget to pay for illegals
we are not happy with the food and they
don't that and according to employees
tons of food get tossed daily by New
York City hotels because the migrants
won't eat it you're hungry you came for
Asylum and you won't eat the food we
give you but if we are paying for them
what are we not funding we're not
funding the police we're not funding
other Americans who have other issues
whether they're senior citizens veterans
in New York city so it's this is a
nightmare and honestly
I think a lot of it is driven by
activists a lot of it is driven by Joe
Biden but and I think a lot of people do
come here to work but but in the end
if you're not grateful you don't have to
stay here
yeah Their Manners could use some
improvement that would help their image
Cotillion for all right it's
embarrassing it's embarrassing for
people like me that say I live in a
sanctuary City I think that we should
live up to that promise you know the
town of Ellis Island as Eric Adams
reference there no one who got off that
boat said I you know inside is worse
than outside right or food is worse than
no food those are your options you
legally do not belong here at least at
this point I hope you will get a pathway
to citizenship I hope that you will be a
great contributor to the New York
economy and then to the greater United
States economy but at this particular
moment
you're here by the grace of our
generosity and to act like that is
terrible the story we covered it a
couple weeks ago the four migrants on
Long Island Who start robbing stores
there should be punishments for that and
there are better people that can take
those spots there are you know I took
the subway yesterday there are a few
homeless people that were on that Subway
asking for money talking about what's
going on with their families they live
on the street with little kids I would
rather that they got those rooms and I'm
happy that they are being pushed out so
that people with kids can get in there
but that facility with their migrant
families they're not homeless families
but I'm saying I'm even happier about
that if you have
a a single guy who's saying that his
skin got a little irritated by the she
I've my Skin's gotten irritated but I
you know people got bed bugs in movie
theaters so what tell me I mean these
things happen but he had a bad reaction
to the Linens yes yes that was a real so
thank you Jesse they can be abrasive yes
I did want to mention one point I think
one thing we should change is that if
you refuse to move to one of these
shelters that is being provided to you
that's an automatic yeah out of here
Deport it's a good you're done and it's
amazing that we even have to make that
stipulation like all right you're
already here illegally uh but and if you
if you don't like what we're giving to
you for free we may have to like we'll
ask you for the second choice Place some
of them didn't even like the original
accommodation but I think that liberals
would support that if you have someone
who really doesn't want to be here under
pretty good conditions I mean people who
go and serve in the Army right yeah like
they sleep in barracks and they want a
ping pong table and a nice piece of
fruit it's really frustrating I didn't
think the mayor had a very good ping
pong game did you see that backhand I
think that you know what I think that's
the real story he here that's my take
this whole 10 minutes was wasted we need
to focus on the ping pong I'm gonna get
the raw footage I'll have that for you
tomorrow an investigation a full
investigation at seven I wanna Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now